[Music]
hey
you guys we are here we would hope
everybody's hungry
yeah today's show is gonna be about
curry
yeah yeah curry it's probably not gonna
be a very long show but you know i'm
just gonna give you guys
the brief background about curry and if
you've never had curry
kind of let you know what it is because
not everybody in the united states has
had curry
british people you tell them curry they
go oh yeah yeah they grew up with the
[ __ ]
well yeah you can get that at like fish
and chip shops everywhere
right and then we're also going to talk
about difference between like authentic
curries and just
the basic street curry that that's what
what's
that's what you're getting today it's
like a it's almost kind of like chinese
fast food
um a lot of the stuff you'll find today
in these indian restaurants they'll
[ __ ] name it and they'll say it's a
chicken curry or a chicken tikka or a
[ __ ]
korma and when you really analyze what
they're doing it's variations on the
same [ __ ] concept over and over again
pretty much same thing that they do in
chinese food
it's the same it's the same methods the
same variations and once you
kind of see the pattern of what they're
doing it's easy to make
okay um now that's not
the same what they sell you on the
street or in these restaurants that's
not the same
as like a an authentic handcrafted
family dish that somebody in india is
making it's not gonna be
you know it's not quite the same um if
you
if you analyze a lot of indian cooking
it's kind of like folk cooking they yeah
they do every person kind of does their
dish their own way
there's a method to the madness but the
variants are
endless usually when it comes to
something that is like official
like official this is like an official
recipe
it's usually some [ __ ] that's coming out
of the taj which is
like the number one top indian
hotel their their restaurant that they
have there at the taj is [ __ ]
fantastic
uh like for instance butter chicken
butter chicken came from the
or from another like high-end hotel or
another high-end in that area
i think butter chicken came from the taj
why didn't it yeah i think it was the
taj mahal but uh
and from there it became authentic
but that's not unusual because a lot of
the so-called
super authentic cajun food is paul
perdome
[ __ ] paul perdom it's from 1960s 70s
it's not that old well the indian food
is like that too it kind of changes with
the times
so what is the curry for you [ __ ]
american luddites that have never had a
[ __ ] curry
curry is a lot like chili chili is a
variation on curry
yeah you know it's like a beef curry
with beans or something
well some people in texas say you would
you ever [ __ ] put
beans and curry this meat in chili i
mean yeah excuse me
it's just meat that's true too i like it
both ways but if you just have like a
beef curry excuse me i'm getting
confused you just got a beef chili
there should it's fantastic there
shouldn't be any beans in it
chili chili con carne yeah chili con
carter yeah
anyway so
okay here's a good example we were we
were at
our favorite we were at one of our
favorite indian restaurants it's called
uh the fifth element
and for this is back when they had the
buffet open
all right and me and jenny were the only
white people in there it's all
indians in there eat and then comes in a
[ __ ] lawn crew
all right you remember those good ass
guys right yeah i remember they got they
had their lawn vehicle out front and
everything
they sat like right behind us yeah right
behind us this big burly redneck
look like these three black dudes they
come walking in and they're they're like
what the hell is this because
he's going y'all gonna love this this is
good you're this is this
and they went out there to go get some
of that curry and it was everything
chicken tikka and curry and kormas they
had all that
and you could just hear them just
[ __ ] mowing down on that [ __ ] back
there and they think they go oh yeah
this is good this is good
he goes this is man's food this is this
is man's food
well he was like telling him once again
and like telling him what was in
everything
and stuff like it was so funny yeah so
it does have a very hearty
curry has a very hearty flavor to it
that appeals
to the masculine side okay it does
women love it too though it's good
but mainly yes but i like it too yeah
yeah feels like iris yeah
well it's not like you know okay this
dude
i knew they were my barometer okay of
acceptance
these guys this is this is working class
dudes you know what i mean and they were
[ __ ] chowing down on that stuff
well that's what they do in india it's
mostly the working class now these are
not the kind of guys that would have
eaten sushi yeah that have been
uh-uh you're gonna cook my fish you know
it's gonna be like that
it's not like you know this it's very
hearty
it's it's like chili and you eat it with
rice or you eat it with flat bread
you know you they'll just kind of sop it
up and bread and eat it and
you can't put it that's one way you can
do it because in india they don't have
they don't really
they tend not to use knives and forks
they'll use a piece of naan bread to
scoop it up out of a bowl yeah i like it
like that they'll even pick up rice like
that you know which i i can't do that
well okay i'm not going that far but
but i really do like i i like it with
rice but
if i had a choice between have it with
rice or have it with non i would rather
have it with none and just scoop it up
with none
now basically what this is is
your t uh to make curry what you're
doing is
you're taking a blend of spices
and you're cooking those spices in
either oil
or clarified butter or clarified butter
butter
okay now if you're going to cook them in
butter it's a little bit more
temperature sensitive
because if the temperature's too high
the butter will scorch and it'll burn
the
the uh it'll burn the the spices
so starting off new what i would do
is start with vegetable oil because
vegetable oil doesn't has a very high
burning point
so it's a little more forgiving in a
temperature you put your spices in the
oil
and and cook it slowly simmer it until
it all kind of darkens and cures
together
all right then the next step
is always something to do with onions
onions is your thickener in these indian
dishes
and then after that your meat and then
after that
water or or some kind of fluid okay so
it could be water
it could be some kind of broth it could
be a mixture of
cream it could be yogurt some people are
going to like yogurt what what the hell
yeah they'll eat just plain yogurt plain
white yogurt
and you can get it from indian stores uh
real cheap
or you can use uh you can use greek
yogurt or just regular generic
flavored yogurt that'll work too you can
get it from the grocery store it's cheap
in the bigger
bigger containers you know and you're
it's all one pot cooking you're cooking
in the same pot same way you do it with
chili
now let's go back to the onions okay
a couple different ways you can do the
onions you want to do the onions
and the spices separately first okay
so what you might want to do is once the
once the uh uh
it all depends on the recipe you're
going to be following a recipe and
and you're going to notice that the
kormas and the curries
and the tikkas are all real similar and
the the recipe is going to
call for a different order of things and
whether or not you're chopping onions or
blending onions
okay but usually the onions and the
spices are
kind of prepared separately first
because you're going to probably use the
onions
as a thickening agent or you're probably
going to put tomato paste in with the
onions there's
going to be a bunch of different things
you have to do
so what i do is i take onions and dice
them and i start cooking them in oil
until they're browned on the edges all
right and depending on
the recipe either the onions will stay
whole or cubed or they're going to be
blended with an immersion
emulsion blender to turn them into a
paste let's say it's going to be a paste
okay once they're brown
i'm going to tip the pot over on its
side and stick my emulsion blender down
in there with that hot oil and just
blend it while it's hot and it'll turn
into a down white
cream then let it cook a little bit more
you'll see the oil separating from the
onions again
then put your spice in there you're
already pre-cooked
you might have put it in a little bowl
just to hold it that'll go in there
and then a lot of times the recipe will
call for tomato
if you have whole tomato just throw it
into a leave it in a can and
use the emulsion blender if it's tomato
paste just put the paste in
okay um now here's something that a lot
of indian restaurants will do and you'll
see
indian chefs talk about add tomato paste
and when you look at the tomato paste
that he's using is damn ketchup
yeah ketchup and they make that's enough
it makes sense
because it's they can you can get it out
of the bottle quickly
you can you you can measure it very
precisely
and a lot of these indian recipes end up
using sugar anyway
the vinegar and stuff kind of burns out
boils out
so it ends up just being tomato paste
and sugar
you're going to add salt later on and
it'll counteract that so
some recipes you'll see with some cooks
they'll just add a bunch of
ketchup to it so you got the spices
the onions and the ketchup and you're
cooking it slowly
kind of reduce it down and then there's
going to be added meat
depending on the recipe the meat might
have been cured it's some kind of meat
maybe it's cubed chicken maybe it's uh
chicken breast maybe it's chicken thigh
boneless maybe it's on the bone each
recipe is going to call for something
different
maybe it's lamb maybe it's a goat maybe
it's fish
maybe it's fish although fish tends to
break apart it's too light and flaky you
want to add that very late in
in a cooking recipe all right for indian
food
uh or maybe a shrimp which you would add
that late too because that only takes a
few minutes to cook
so but the standard is chicken or lamb
so you're going to throw that in there
and you're just going to cook it on low
all right for a long time until attempt
till it kind of tenderizes now
some recipes will say well slow cook it
first
in other words they're telling you to
pre-cook the meat which that comes out
real good
if you have a pressure cooker you can
pre-cook that meat make it tender just
in a few minutes
yeah and that's what a lot of those
restaurants are doing with lamb it's
pressure cooked
and if you don't have a pressure cooker
then you just [ __ ] out of luck you're
[ __ ]
what the hell are you doing with the
kitchen you don't have a pressure cooker
you gotta have a [ __ ] pressure cooker
all right they don't cost that much go
buy you a pressure cooker
and they don't explode like they used to
they don't explode
so if it's lamb or anything it's kind of
tough that would take a long time to
slow cook it pressure cook it first and
then just pour it and it's fluids didn't
into the damn curry mix the last stage
is usually adding the [ __ ] dairy okay
which is either going to be cream or
yogurt or both
and maybe a little bit of water to thin
it out sometimes it might be some kind
of a broth to thin it out
each recipe is going to call for
something different and then it's going
to
end that's going to you're going to come
to the end of cooking that
indian dish it's gonna look kind of
strange
sometimes to a westerner because you
might see oil floating on it
indians eat a lot of oil when you see
oil
separating from the cooked spices you
know that it's cooked right
so you'll see and it also some of it
doesn't have it depends on what it is
like tikkas
i tend to be pink and there's no oil in
it just pay attention to the photographs
you can go on youtube and see
indians of alderman types you know girls
at home
cooking it old ladies at home cooking
things a lot of times their english
isn't good
but if you already kind of know
generally the recipe because you read
you're reading it you can see what
they're doing you go okay i see and
you'll understand why they did that
now as a general rule of thumb just like
chili
curry is better on the second and third
day oh yeah big time
yeah kind of want to make a lot of it
because it's got spices in it it's it's
it's naturally preserved
i've cooked curries before and they've
been good for over a week
in the refrigerator yeah yeah and i
would think a lot of those indian homes
especially in the poor neighborhoods
don't have a refrigerator it sits in a
pot
probably up against in a cupboard bugs
crawling on it probably
and probably good for a week because
and it's hot down there because the the
spices just kind of
ba before refrigeration they use spices
as preservatives
so you know takes a long time for things
to to rot
when there's [ __ ] spices on but this
is a very general outline and an
introduction to
cooking curries curries is kind of like
the time we did the shows on sauces
they got sauciers out there that [ __ ]
cook a million different sauces that's
all they do is they're just sauce
experts indian foods kind of like that
too there's a bunch of different
variations on curry some
are just vegetables vegetable type
curries
uh you just you know
look and then they'll give it a fancy
name like vindaloo
to me vindaloo is just vegetable curry
the process is very similar but it's
more
some i think some families might use
that as a side dish i don't really know
but everything everything in there
everything in their repertoire tastes
like
uh one pot cooking uh it's
it's variations on the same theme over
and over again you cook one of those
dishes you basically cooked them all
that's a lot of it yeah it's just it's
basically like a meat or
or a main vegetable in a sauce yeah
either served over rice or with naan or
with both
yeah is it on the bone or off the bone
is it
creamier or is it more tomatoey is it
is it is it savory or is it more sweet
it's just variations of the same things
is it
is it more is it more turmeric or is it
more
garam masala or or more cumin that's
another thing
the basic indian spice blend is
something called garam masala
which is just like masala means spicy it
probably just means like spicy mix or
some [ __ ] like that
and if you can't find garam masala there
are recipes for garam masala [ __ ]
and it's just a usually it's a mixture
of things like cumin
turmeric some kind of chili powder
um what else is in that coriander
cinnamon maybe
maybe cinnamon maybe coriander maybe a
little bit of clove
they're family versions of
of garam masala garam masala is the very
basic spice mix most recipes will call
for a certain amount of garam masala but
then they'll say
but and three tablespoons of turmeric or
and
two tablespoons of of of chili powder
so um you know you just got to go by the
recipe each recipe is
different you know let me go let's see
if there's any questions in the
comments i wanted to mention too that
even though curry is kind of like a
really
generic term and they kind of make a lot
of the stuff the same way
but even some dishes that are called
different things
are made in a similar way yeah i mean
because like i said say
for example like you're talking about a
biryani but
that's kind of like the same thing
except you layer it between layers of
rice and it's like slightly different
but it's not really all that different
yeah the the cool thing about a lot of
indian cooking is if you kind of learn
the process then you can pretty much
make
a wide variety of things because
mostly it you know mostly the process
this
is the same it's just sometimes the
spice mix is a little different or the
order is a little bit different
but it's pretty much the same stuff i
was going to ask too because you said
about um
using uh you know the onion paste as a
thickener
some of them have like um you know like
nut paste
too like almond paste or or something
made out of cashews or cashews yeah
some of it's almonds um and then you can
go
uh you you also tend to have to make
ginger garlic paste you can buy ginger
garlic paste
from from an indian store yeah it comes
in a big jar
and it's just ground ginger and ground
garlic together and it saves you a lot
of time
so ginger garlic paste is usually in
there uh it's just
one of the things that they use they use
it almost kind of like a cooking
condiment i mean you
it's like a base for cooking things
that's usually added
kind of like towards the end part of
where the onions are starting to brown
sometimes it's done in with the spices
at the same time too there's
a couple different variations another
variation is is instead of cream
or instead of um yogurt
they're gonna put in uh coconut milk
yeah but that's indians will do that but
that's kind of
more of a thai thing that's like
they would consider that to be kind of
some foreign flair but i have seen them
use it
well and amanda was saying too that
she's lactose intolerant so she uses
coconut milk when she makes indian food
just because she can't have cream you
know what i mean yeah so yeah it's a
totally acceptable and we've used it
before yeah well like you said that is
more
and the weird thing about it too is that
you know all throughout asia really you
know there's thai food there's stuff
like that they call
curry but it's not exactly the same
thing yeah it's just kind of like i said
it's very general term
yeah like brianne is really more like
indian jambalaya
yeah that's a good yeah it's a rice and
meat dish
you cooked you cooked
to do it the right way you're cooking
everything in one big old pot and
usually it's a whole damn lamb
on a bed of rice yeah it's all kind of
with piled up on rice and cooked in one
pot
they're doing crazy [ __ ] like that that
would be like briyani all right
but at home usually what you're doing is
cooking the rice and the meat separately
and then once it's all done you add it
together and layer it together to make a
rice dish
that has spiced meats in the middle of
it
kind of like jambalaya but it's layered
yeah like a lasagna
yeah kind of yeah
but if you actually were to analyze what
you've done
the meat and spice segment of the dish
is like a very condensed curry that's
what i was getting at yeah
it's just that the the blend of spices
might be different
um and it's the same thing for like what
you'd get on the street for korma
kormas are variations on curry yeah but
it's brown all right but street curry is
disturbing street korma
and street curry is not the same as the
real
deal korma is not indian in in the way
you would think it is
korma is mogul they were kind of like
the islamic invaders that when
came into into india a long time ago
and that was one of their dishes and it
was like curry
they'll make it like curry but but
the real dish wasn't really like it it
was
uh it was an onion excuse me it was
onions and
almond paste based
curry uh that had lamb in it
or goat and it was put in a pot and then
the lid on the pot was sealed up
with um it's like some kind of dough red
dough
to keep the moisture from ex from from
from escaping
and it was cooked very slowly over a
long period of time kind of like a crock
pot cooking
yeah and uh well to do that in a
restaurant is
you just you just don't have time time
prohibited
so they you can execute karma in a way
in the same way you would make curry too
it's just another variation of it um
it'll save you a lot of time um let me
see what else
and memories of india one of our
favorite indian restaurants around here
um they have their lamb korma is amazing
that's like my favorite thing
somebody uh mango was asking if we had
made anything with cheese like sog
paneer
oh yeah yes we have mice all the time
yeah sock paneer is actually one of my
favorite indian dishes i have to say i
love paneer i can eat anything yeah you
can also take the paneer out and do that
same
dish basically with chicken that's good
too or put chicken and paneer or chicken
we've done that as well
but yeah well actually when we went to
when the uh buffet was still open at
fifth element
one of my favorite things they made was
like chicken tikka but it was paneer
instead of chicken
man that [ __ ] was delicious i could have
just eaten that yeah for people who
don't know what chicken tikka is
it's small pieces of chicken meat
boneless
in kind of a pink gravy pink sauce it's
nice it's mild creamy
it's um savory with
um yeah there's no way to describe it uh
other than that is it i've seen tikka
done with like full pieces of chicken
too
yeah it could be you can yeah you can do
it on the bonuses
it's just you know i guess at the um at
the what you call it they uh
at the buffet it's easier it's just yeah
have it all cut off a chicken
now there's a bunch of um vegetable
versions of curry
uh sometimes it's whole vegetables or
not whole but what would you call it
uh sometimes it's things like lentils
like doll which is like
yellow yellow like chickpeas
no doll is no doll is like yellow
green like green peas but they're yellow
and they're split like a split pea
that's
dal yeah it's a lentil you can make that
you can make curry out of that
you can also make curry out of chickpeas
i have a bunch of dried chickpeas that
they use
now the thing is with that is that you
have to soak them
even if you soak them for a long time
you're probably not going to get those
things to fully rehydrate
i found the best thing to do is to
pressure cook that
pressure it doesn't take long few
minutes you pressure cook
peas or um anything dry peas dried
uh chickpeas you might pressure cook it
amanda was saying too that her favorite
uh vegetable curry that she made was
either she had one with chickpeas and
carrots or she did one with cauliflower
which is also actually really
well i don't know if we've ever we've
maybe made a cauliflower one a couple of
times they've had it
yeah but i've had it at russia they had
it down there with the cauliflower and
different kinds of squash yeah that was
good yeah i like that
yeah like tomato in it sometimes yeah uh
indian food is kind of like the ultimate
poor people food
and people what the hell you talking
about yeah india is poor but
most countries were poor when their
cuisine started including american food
start off as poor people food
it's very easy to take an expensive
component and make that taste good
there's no challenge because you're just
letting the component speak for itself
yeah that's why it's expensive
the challenge is to take something
that's cheap and plentiful
that nobody really wants and to turn
that into something that tastes
fantastic
and the indians did a really good job at
that and so did the mexicans
a lot of mexican food is stuff that on
its own if it
you know there's nothing to it it's just
corn corn
and pork that's bad that's the basis of
most of what they eat
yeah um waka which is uh
they call it thanks avocado onion a
little bit tomato
and with that they can [ __ ] do
anything with corn they can make
tortillas
which who would have thought of that
they didn't you wouldn't think of that
you know so
indian food is like one of the one of
the best of the poor people food that
you eat like a king
now there's some dietary problems with
it though
it's very hit very high in carbohydrates
very heavy in pretty bad oils
with vegetable oil did pretty bad a lot
of meat oils that too in it too
the cooking process releases a lot of
oil
if that bothers you kick the [ __ ]
pot over to the side and scoop that oil
up out of there and throw it away
an indian would drink that like nothing
just suck it up
because don't waste it that's good stuff
yeah well it makes sense under their
conditions they're probably not getting
a whole lot of a protein
and you know what i mean so uh having
fats kind of gives you that feeling of
being full
yep you know what i mean because
carbohydrates give you a carbohydrate
crash and you'll get [ __ ] sleepy and
then you get hungry again
so eating fat under that condition you
know it's probably pretty good because
you're trying to get every bit of
every bit of nutrition out of every meal
you get if you're living out somewhere
in indian hood trying to survive on
[ __ ] 30 40 cents a day
then yeah but the most common thing that
they eat out there
in the indian hood is something called
sambal which is kind of like a
spicy vegetable noodle and rice
stew and you can get a big old cup of
sod ball for
a few few pennies
and that's like their version of a
burger and fries
of fact gordon ramsay was making
soundball with remember yeah that's
right
yeah i really actually did like we um i
bought him
for his birthday or christmas or
something a long time ago gordon
ramsay's indian cookbook
yeah because he went all around india
and like cooked with all
he made a tv show out of it it was good
but it was good but
his spice ratios were way too mild he
got yeah so he airs on the side of my
well like i said it's easy
to add more if you want it spicier
it's even too mild for me and i like it
mild i respect ramsay but he's a [ __ ]
when it comes to when it comes to things
that are hot he's oh that's hot
i don't understand it well maybe you
know he does have expensive taste buds
so he doesn't want to burn his taste
buds out i guess
well yeah and like i said i don't mind
stuff that's a little bit spicy but
after a time it's like i want to be able
to taste the food not the heat
he'd never make it down south in
louisiana or mexico where shit's [ __ ]
hot
you know because i feel like sometimes
people just like to eat hot food because
they're like
i'm better than you ate hot food you
know what i mean but it's like cause
i'm like i don't i don't see the point
of it up to us after a certain point
because you can't really taste anything
there's some kind of heat i just [ __ ]
love it it depends on the type of heat
that it is
right i mean but even when i get indian
food because i know there's kind of
and maybe this is still like a
misperception but i think people feel
like
you know indian food or thai food is
like all really hot and it's not
i mean you can get [ __ ] if you go to any
indian restaurant you can tell them you
want it mild and it's like they might
look at you funny but they'll still make
it like that
yeah you know and and honestly i usually
prefer to get it that way like
either mild or medium because if it gets
too hot
i just like i said i'm not i don't
really enjoy it because i feel like i'm
just fighting with the food and also
it's gonna upset my stomach later uh
whereas if it's mild it won't
but you know what i mean so i don't know
but um
you know that everything's not hot yeah
but if you guys have uh
listening you've never had indian food
go to your local indian restaurant or go
to one that's rated pretty well
on yelp or whatever and go down there
and get you some
get some chicken curry chicken tikka
something like that go to a buffet
so you can try like lots of different
things let's try different things and
then uh
pick one you like and then go home and
research that and see if you can execute
that
i was going to say too if you're a
vegetarian um there are a lot of really
really good vegetarian indian dishes
because a lot of the dishes are so good
like sog paneer doesn't have meat in it
yeah um and
obviously you can't it's not vegan
because it has paneer and that's cheese
but if you're a vegetarian then [ __ ] i
could i could eat that all the time and
not even miss the meat in it i wanted to
say that uh kyle alexander says huge fan
of the channel first time watching live
what's up
well hey welcome kyle yeah now here's
some other advice i'm gonna give you
you're gonna find all kinds of crazy ass
indian rice's out there
basmati and uh you know jasmine
uh and over and over again it's been
confirmed not only by my own experience
but by
the the recommendations of other indian
people and [ __ ] pakistani women that
cook this stuff too
or things like this they will tell you
over and over again you want to get
a brand called royal with and that's
what i get
royal basmati yeah we get that big
20-pound bag get a big
20-pound bag it comes in a big burlap
bag
two handles on the top of it yeah it's
brown burlap with red and blue it says
royal on it
and that's their best one a lot of that
other stuff it's harder to cook it's not
as forgiving
it either falls apart or it's gummy it
doesn't get fluffy enough
uh but no if you're if you're pimping
and you're in india you're by royal
you don't buy that other [ __ ] and the
difference in price
well the difference in price can be
almost twice as twice as expensive
actually
it's good though but still good it's not
you can get a big bag of it for like uh
twenty five thirty dollars yeah that's
like that's like a twenty pound bag
right
is it ten pounds or twenty pounds it's a
big bag that's
forever yeah because we only make like
two cups of rice at a time
yeah yeah and it comes out like pretty
much perfect
every single time like it's it's exactly
right it's just
exactly fluffy it's not too soft long
narrow grains
and they have a slight almond flavor to
them
yeah it's kind of nutty yeah and you
don't have to add anything
you can you can we have but you don't
have to add anything if you don't want
to i mean
throw some cardamom pods in there
cardamom pods a little bit
like a thing of cinnamon like a little
star and yeast star
nice in there maybe a a couple basil
leaves
but you put that in oil first or butter
first
yeah and and cook it in the bottom of
the pan and let it release
and then you throw the rice in there and
the water and cover it cook as normal
and it'll come back it'll just be
beautiful
yep completely fluffy every single time
and it'll be brown and with all the full
spices and throw the spices out that
rice is
perfect yeah amanda said the reason i've
drifted toward indian food is because
it's mostly vegetarian friendly yeah
yeah yeah
pretty much anything can be made
vegetarian any dish
yeah indian food's the only vegetarian
food that is acceptable to me in terms
of flavor
it's it's got a robust flavor i'm
satisfied with it
so i'll eat that a lot of other
vegetarian food and uh
there's nothing then it's not working
with anything it's just not impressive
well it's just because i mean indian
food is so
focused on it's so spice focused yeah
that
it and it has like all these really
complex spicy flavors and they all like
work so well together
that even if you're just eating
vegetables you know just cauliflower or
whatever
it makes everything taste so luscious
yeah that you don't really feel like
you're not
like oh you know i miss the meat or
anything like that like i said i could
eat saag paneer
every day and not get not really missed
meat
at all because it's so good yeah
nutrition wise i had to go back over
this nutrition wise
you don't want to be a vegetarian i mean
if you're a vegetarian
you want to supplement that with some
kind of a protein like uh
whey protein drinks maybe uh you're also
going to want some
whatever that [ __ ] was called i forgot i
don't have to worry about it too much
and where i get enough protein
but you know i have people [ __ ] in
the comments oh no i i've been working
out for 30 years and i'm i'm a
vegetarian and this and that and
yeah but there's no vegetarians have
ever won olympia
okay just no vegetarians have won
olympia and that's the that's the
[ __ ] top pinnacle
of the [ __ ] mass monsters if you're
on any kind of anabolic [ __ ] steroids
and [ __ ] like that
no you're gonna have to have lots of
protein a lot of those guys are eating
them
two dozen eggs a day when you look at
what those [ __ ] eat
it's amazing it has to have lots of
protein i have to have minimal amount of
calories
and that's tends to be the problem with
with vegetarian diets
there's not a lot of protein to make the
to make the protein requirements then
you have to eat
[ __ ] nine ten twenty thousand damn
calories a day so very high in calorie
if you're trying to achieve the protein
levels you need the protein because once
you get up to a certain size
your body is just a protein synthesized
synthesizing [ __ ] machine
you'll lose muscle mass and you know if
you
if you're if you're [ __ ]
5 15 lean and weighing [ __ ] 200 200
[ __ ] pounds plus
that's a lot of [ __ ] lean body mass
you got to maintain
vegetables won't cut it now a lot of
those guys there's a lot of now some
guys will show up
here's my pictures pictures of me as a
vegetarian this and that that's all that
[ __ ]
coming off instagram i've researched it
over and over again with [ __ ]
professionals that are into this
there's things out there called fake
natties or excuse me fake veggies
vegetarians
god claims he's a vegetarian but he's
not and then he's also doing a bunch of
steroids
and doing it on a bunch of peds so it's
just
don't believe what people say that's
this one
don't believe what people say until you
see [ __ ] blood work and then you can
start believing
i'm not worried about it yeah um all
right so uh amanda said basmati rice is
the only rice that is not cooking
kryptonite for me this is embarrassing
for me because i lived in an asian
nation
it really does seem like the style of
rice
that works out the best most of the time
because i feel like
i feel like yeah because i feel like a
lot of people have trouble
with various other bits of rice you know
you overcook it you undercook it you
know it's too hard it's too soft it's
too gummy it's whatever
but basmati seems to come out yeah as
long as you do it because we do it
exactly the same every time you put two
cups in a
measuring cup you soak it in water for a
little while
then you take the vat you put it in the
pan and
with uh we usually do two cups of rice
to three cups of water yeah
yeah yeah i think it's two to three and
then you put that in there you put the
lid on it
let the pot boil and then take it off
the heat for a minute and then like put
it back on there and then just let it
sit
another thing you can do is that you can
have a little bit of oil on the bottom
of the pan
and you can drop the pre-soaked rice
grains
into the oil and and you can you can
toast to the rice yeah
before you add the water yeah you don't
have to do that but that that
that is good too it kind of releases
more of a little nutty flavor to it
um but yeah
but yeah yeah yeah i'm just trying to
think if there's anything else
to say about it see if there's any more
questions about that
yeah i don't hopefully it's not gonna uh
crash because
i haven't got any new chat for a little
bit
yeah oracle says there's a rice variety
known as tex mati here
variation on buzz i've actually never
heard of that yeah um
i have problems with some of the most
common rice i have a lot of problem
cooking parboiled rice the cheap
american par boi i do as well it turns
into mush
yeah it never comes out right it's very
sensitive to
to the actual pot that you're cooking it
in yeah it wants a pot of a certain size
a certain dimension it's got to be a
certain thickness on the bottom of the
pot
if you try to get away it doesn't i
tried everything even tried
rinsing the rice off before doing it it
just comes out like [ __ ] mush or
splits apart it's just real i haven't
mastered that rice yet
and that's and that's supposed to be
like your
basic [ __ ] right yeah that's like the
easy race that's
yeah all the time yeah i do as well
yeah we use that for yeah and that same
thing happened i got some that jasmine
rice
and that was even harder than par boiled
rice and you'll follow the
destruct the instructions to the letter
and it'll still come out like [ __ ]
like gummy or or still hard
one way or the other and it has to do
with the size of the pot
the dimensions of the pot is it a pot or
is it a pan
yeah because we use kind of for making
rice we usually use like a skillet but
with higher sides
you have to find out you have to find
which pot which pot it likes
yeah and it's not telling you
you can ask it all you want and it
doesn't talk
yeah the tex mate is a hybrid of long
grain american rice and basmati
that's interesting i had never actually
heard of that what are what dishes they
use that in
interesting but yeah seriously did you
have anything else you needed to add
you don't have any no hugo says that
toasting rice is how they make it in
mexico yeah
there's a lot of good mexican variations
of rice a lot of good spanish rice too
that you you'd find in mexico sometimes
but you can you can make that you can
make that from nothing
you know just uh turmeric turmeric and
then whatever your vegetables are maybe
uh
chicken stock that's the easiest way
yeah
yeah all right that's it
all right so that'll do it for our on
the menu show tomorrow
we're going to do a matinee we're going
to talk about
the mummy the tom cruise one yeah yes
mommy we finally broke down and watched
it yeah
i could do it i gave it a hit i liked it
jimmy didn't like it i liked it
i thought it was okay i liked it i
didn't love it i didn't hate it
but i didn't love it i was expecting a
[ __ ] dumpster fire it
i had a phone i had fun watching it i'll
talk we'll talk about it tomorrow yeah
we'll talk about it tomorrow
three o'clock because i i kind of want
to get into it like like i said i'm not
gonna like [ __ ] on it too much or
anything but it's like i didn't hate it
it was all right
anthony bourdain alright okay all right
so uh
that'll do it for today's live stream
thanks everybody for dropping by
have a good rest of your afternoon and
we will see you guys tomorrow
bye